be a writer I know you want to be right
really why do you always call me a dirty
little [ __ ] ah just because maybe you're
jealous that I'm more successful than
you
I would not like to turn to the person
next to you hi is it possible he could
do a three-way I've never done a
three-way why are you in this class you
seem so together I'm so glad you told me
things on a voicemail like hey by the
way I'm [ __ ] a 19 year old I saved it
and I play it for my friend and then I
tell him about your weird dick I've been
dating this guy for two years I love you
as his friend and as a sexual partner
won't love I want to have hot sex with
someone who's really nice to me yeah
your boobs are too big and they make you
look like a bimbo all right should I be
taking out some of the stuff for the
sexual harassment lawsuit we're all
going to why are we sitting around
talking about how sad our lives are
you're right we should be talking about
how great we are
I thought you were desperate and too old
I hate that you're not into me makes me
so much more attracted to you yeah we
talk about pleasing men but what about
pleasing us I'm a cliche a handsome guy
runs off with a younger hot sexy girl
I'm a hunter I gotcha I found ya I kept
her for a little bit and then I got
bored and then you left and now I'm
attracted to you again they could I
leave my laundry here get it out
Thursday you want me to do your laundry
while you date other women you should do
your laundry you should feel lucky to
tap that ass hey you are so hot like
really hot
let's make a pact to be with good guys
only guys who treat us great like we
deserve I feel like guys I'll go down
you aren't hetero enough ooh
oh this guy if he asked me out he's
super attractive you should go for it
move over there's a new skank in town
having sex with me is a religious
experience let's just go have sex in my
office makes me want to like vomit in my
mouth I want you to do my laundry now
and the best sex of my life
bossed me around some more kind of
turned me on
look so high I won't have sex with you
okay no I just spent an hour singing
about my [ __ ] experience I didn't know
I had
you